merci de m'avoir invité et je pense
que c'est l'un des problèmes qui se pose,
donc je pense encore une fois que le
gouvernement américain ne fonctionne pas
de la manière dont le président
responsable
et inverse de nombreuses procédures d'atout
est plus important,
donc c'est un très bon  question
quand vous gardez en fait
ceux qui sont très fondamentaux
[Music]
euh qui sont là pour faire en quelque sorte
euh
[Music]
par exemple
je veux dire que cela nous parle de revenir en arrière
parce que nous ne croyons pas que les
individus que nous  ne sommes pas le Far West,
nous ne sommes pas le euh
euh
plutôt que
oui, ce sera et je veux dire, vous savez qu'il y va
déjà définitivement
en même temps, mais je pense que la grande victoire
est déjà arrivée en disant qu'il
était responsable
[  Musique]
euh
et nous avons cette hypothèse qu'ils
sont de mauvaises personnes dans les nations
car nous avons parlé de qui était à la
maison blanche sa fille était à la
maison blanche sa fille qui je crois est